this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war fun to check
out this game through the link in the
description below going through that
link not any supports this show P also
get a free premium tank or aircrafts in
three days of premium time as a bonus
and let's get into it during the late
19th century a German man named otto
lilienthal achieved some of the first
successful repeated flights using
gliders regrettably he suffered a crash
on August the 9th 1896 and he died the
next day reportedly his last words were
sacrifices must be made
this was mentally shared by all the
pioneers of flight during the inception
of aviation there were few professions
out there that were more dangerous a
quick look at all the pilots from the
first decades of flight and you will
find that very few of them got to see
retirements after a long and successful
career if you'll pardon the cliche
these men were simply made of sterner
stuff than the rest one of these
Daredevils was Australian Charles
Kingsford Smith he discovered his
passion for flying during World War one
and for the rest of his life he always
looked for new opportunities to soar
through the skies in the process he set
a number of world firsts such as the
first trans-pacific flight from the
United States to Australia unfortunately
like many of his peers Kingsford Smith's
career ended in tragedy and his final
resting place remains to this day a
mystery
born on February the 9th 1897 in
Hamilton a suburb of Brisbane Australia
Charles Edward Kingsford Smith was the
seventh child of a banker named William
Charles Smith and Catherine Mary nee
Kingsford although the family originally
simply went by Smith they added the
surname Kingsford in 1903 when they
relocated to Canada the move did not
last long and in 1907 the Kingsford
Smith's were back in Australia but this
time in Sydney
Charles became known as smithy a
nickname that he would carry for the
rest of his life when he was nine years
old
Charles almost drowned bondi beach when
he got dragged out to sea by rip
currents the young boys struggled to
stay afloat but eventually lost
consciousness he was saved just in time
by the lifeguard service which had only
recently come into existence and he was
resuscitated by a nurse he was in the
right place at the right time later
during his aviation grip people said
that Kingsford Smith was terrified of
flying over the ocean and would get sick
whenever he did it this event at the
beach may have been the genesis of his
angst as a teenager
Charles enrolled as a Technical School
where he studied to become an engineer
he also joins the senior cadets a
military youth organization after the
outbreak of World War one Kingsford
Smith enlisted in the Australian
Imperial force in February 1915 13
year-old took part in the Gallipoli
campaign where he served as a sapper
with the forth signal troop second
division Signal Company this is where he
had his second brush with death as he
described in a letter to his parents he
heard some ping noises very close to him
when he finally reached shelter
Kingsford Smith noticed that a bullet
had come so close to his head that it
afraid the edge of his cap later he
became a dispatch rider during campaigns
in Egypt and France after being promoted
to sergeant smithy transferred to the
Australian Flying Corps in October of
1916 this is where he got his first
taste of flying and developed a passion
that would follow him for the rest of
his life he trained in England where he
showed immediate aptitude as a pilot he
was commissioned as second lieutenant
with the Royal Flying Corps the RFC the
precursor to the Royal Air Force
Kingsford Smith he was sent to the
French front as part of the number 23
squadron there he shot down four enemy
aircraft as well as launching multiple
attacks on ground targets and balloons
inevitably Smithee was bested in a
dogfight and was shot down himself he
walked away from the crowd
although his injuries did require
amputation of several toes Kingsford
Smith received the Military Cross for
conspicuous gallantry and devotion to
duty because his recuperation would take
a long time he was allowed to visit his
parents and Australia and upon returning
was promoted to captain and assigned as
a flying instructor by the time smithy
was fully healed the war it had ended he
wasn't sure what you wanted to do with
his life but he knew that it had to
involve flying he teamed up with another
pilot named Cyril Maddox and formed a
joy flight company that offered pleasure
airplane trips throughout England
however the young Smith was already
looking for opportunities that would
bring him fame and fortune in 1919
Australian Prime Minister Billy Hughes
announced the great air race a prize of
10,000 pounds would be awarded to the
first person who completed a flight from
Great Britain to Australia in under 30
days unsurprisingly Kingsford Smith
wanted to take part in that race but he
was denied membership into the Royal
Aero Club of Australia RAC a and by
defaults entry ins the competition
officials were concerned over Smithy's
lack of navigational experience over the
11,000 180 mile route and thought that
it would be dangerous let him race
instead the prize was claimed by
brothers sir Ross and Keith Macpherson
Smith although he was not allowed to
compete in the great air race an idea
sprouted in Smithy's mind there was
another surefire way to glory
the first trans-pacific flight from the
United States to Australia spoiler alert
this would be the feat that brought him
everlasting fame but now was not the
time Kingsford Smith traveled to America
to search for sponsors for his daring
escapade but he failed to find any he
occupied his time with other flying gigs
which included stunt work for a circus
and for Hollywood movies however he saw
another pilot die in an accident and
decided that the job was too risky even
for him he returned to Australia in 1921
[Music]
he might have had it with life as a
stunt pilots but the experience did not
detract from Smithy's pleasure of flying
back home he started another joy flying
company he also became a salaried pilot
with West Australian Airways started by
another RFC veteran sir Norman Brearley
this was the first Australian airline
with a scheduled air service his
personal life Smith II married dharma
eileen hope cowboy in 1923 by all
accounts it was an unhappy marriage that
only lasted a few years as Kingsford
Smith was not made for a stable life in
one place his biographer he and McCarthy
said that the Aviators mind was always
in the sky thinking about the next time
that he would be able to fly when he was
on the ground Kingsford Smith he enjoyed
women booze and spending his money
almost as fast as he made it smithy
believed there was a huge potential for
an airmail service in Australia together
with another aviator called Charles um
he started the interstate flying
services but found it difficult securing
contracts to show people that ml was the
future the two pilots wanted to perform
some demonstration flights to attract
sponsors and investors they did a round
trip of Australia in a little over ten
days which garnered plenty of attention
sensing an opportunity to secure funding
Kingsford Smith forgot all about his
airmail business and instead once again
promoted his true dream the
trans-pacific flight this time it worked
Kingsford Smith not only obtained a
grant from the government of New South
Wales but also received financial
backing from two businessman Myer
department store founder Sydney Marr and
California oil tycoon George Allen
Hancock first off they had to buy a
plane smithy and own traveled all the
way to America to find the one that they
wanted but bizarrely they ended up
buying one from another Australian
specifically they purchased a Fokker
Evan from polar explorer Sir Hubert
Wilkins it started life as the Detroiter
but Smith rechristened it the Southern
Cross the goal was to take off from
Oakland California and finish in
Australia this was not a nonstop flight
so they would need to refuel two times
the first of which would be in Hawaii
over the previous year ten pilots had
died attempting to do this leg of the
trip and the odds they were not in their
favor but the airmen were determined to
carry
on Kingsford Smith at a four-man team he
was the pilot while Ulm acted as relief
pilots on board were also two Americans
James Warner who was the radio operator
and Harry Leon who served as navigator
the foursome took off from Auckland on
May the 31st 1928 they reached the
islands of Kauai to refuel after an
uneventful 27 hours from there they set
off on the longest stage of their
journey to Fiji to make matters worse
they encountered a massive lightning
storm but nevertheless they reached the
island of Suva in one piece the final
stage saw them fly into Brisbane Airport
to a hero's welcome as tens of thousands
of people cheered them on after 83 hours
and 38 minutes of flying time Kingsford
Smith and his crew completed the first
ever trans-pacific flight now just
before we continue on the adventure
today I do want to quickly thank the
sponsor of today's episode war thunder
you know a lot of flying in this episode
and you can do it without all the danger
and expense in war funds of the best way
is for me to show you that so let's jump
over to the computer so welcome to war
thunder I've played planes before
anything in a couple of these low reads
but tanks are also fun new players
Germany because why not also in war
thunder there are 1200 different
vehicles that you can choose from and
different modifications you can do if
you just you're in the hangar here you
can do the modification seek you can add
different parts and uninstall things
like if you really want to you can
uninstall the brake system okay so it's
kind of like a capture the flag sort of
stylee thing that's we're gonna be doing
it's a seven uh nap down
that'd be do Drake up again a battle
come on man oh look he does look to the
side oh this many enemies all there are
many enemies that's why that I do yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna take a puppet I'm
just I'm just basically
Oh
the initial light burns yeah that did
not look good oh look here comes that's
going strain to my body oh oh that's
incredible but these four dudes aren't
sighs so that is war thunder join us on
the battlefield for free using the link
below doing that sports the show and
also gets you a free premium tank or
aircraft and three days of premium time
as a bonus for registering and let's get
back to it
[Music]
Kingsford Smith received a ton of
rewards for his feet including the Air
Force cross an honorary position as
Squadron Leader with the Royal
Australian Air Force and over 20,000
pounds in funding now that the
trans-pacific flight was out of the way
he could focus again on his more
practical ambition that of establishing
an air now company in August of 1928
just a few months after his journey
across the Pacific smithy performed the
first nonstop flight across mainland
Australia taking off from point Kirk
near Melbourne and landing in Perth less
than a month later he already had a new
ambition to be the first to fly across
the Tasman Sea to New Zealand's not only
wish this have been neither gratifying
feather in Smithy's aviator cap but he
hopes that it would also secure an NR
contract between the two countries at
the time achieving the first
trans-tasman flight was the next big
thing for many Australian and New
Zealand aviators however in January of
that year two Kiwi pilots named John
moncreif and George Hood disappeared
over the sea while attempting the flight
no trace of their plane has ever been
found
Kingsford Smith's venture in September
1928 was the first attempt since their
disappearance he had a crew of four
again Charles em was by his side as
relief pilots and joining them were
radio operator Thomas McWilliams and
navigator Harold
Arthur Litchfield they boarded the
Southern Cross and took off on September
the 10th after a flight of 14 hours and
25 minutes they landed at Wigram Airport
in Christchurch tens of thousands of
people were there to cheer them on
including students and public servants
who were given the day off for this
momentous occasion
[Music]
with another world first under his belt
Kingsford Smith was the talk of the town
once again but he would soon find
himself involved in a few controversies
with fatal consequences that have a
lasting impact on his reputation
now that the trans-tasman flesh was also
out of the way Kingsford Smith's
pragmatic side started showing again in
1929 he intended to fly to England
purchase for new aircraft for his
budding company took a crew with him
aboard the Southern Cross but had to
make an emergency landing in the middle
of nowhere
in Western Australia the crew was safe
but the plane was in no condition to fly
so they patiently waited for rescue
of course the disappearance of a hero of
the statue of Charles Kingsford Smith
prompted a massive search involving many
other pilots among them were two of his
friends named Keith Anderson and Bobby
Hitchcock they flew aboard the
Kookaburra hoping to spot a sign of the
downed airplane unfortunately they also
suffer problems and crash-landed in the
Tanami desert while smithy and his crew
would be found and rescued these two
pilots died of exposure it hardly seemed
fair to blame Kingsford Smith for the
tragedy but rumors soon started
circulating that the forced landing of
the Southern Cross had been nothing but
a publicity stunt the media sends to
juice historians fans the flames of
controversy some even accused the
aviator of purposefully making it harder
for search teams to find them that way
the longer they stayed gone the more
press they would receive the incident
became known as the coffee roll affair
named so after the black coffee and
brandy drink which the crew of the
Southern Cross purportedly drank while
awaiting rescue an official inquiry was
launched into the matter and although
Kingsford Smith was exonerated his
reputation
it was tarnished in Australia
overseas everyone still loved smithy so
he climbed into his trusty Southern
Cross and took to the skies for a few
more headline-grabbing flights in June
1930 he completed an east-west crossing
of the Atlantic from Ireland to America
and thirty one and a half hours this
also meant that he had completed a
circumnavigation of the world which he
first started with his trans-pacific
journey later that year he won an air
race from England to Australia breaking
the speed record while flying solo
alongside Charles ohm in 1929 smithy
finally founded the airline that he had
dreamed of for years which he called
Australian national Airways it commenced
operations in January of 1930 with five
airplanes with Kingsford Smith himself
flying the southern cloud the company
wasn't around for long though the
airline had to close down following
another landmark moment in the history
of aviation but won the Kingsford Smith
could certainly have done without the
first airliner to disappear during a
flight on March the 21st 1931 the
southern cloud left Sydney for Melbourne
Kingsford Smith was not the one flying
on board with two crewmen and six
passengers they all perished in a crash
in the snowy mountains of New South
Wales due to bad weather the final
location he remained a mystery for 27
years until a hiker named Tom Sumpter
stumbled upon the wreckage he goes to
show that back then being a passenger on
an airplane took about as much courage
as being a pioneering aviator Southern
Sun also crashed while trying to make
the first m/l delivery from Australia to
England Charles Kingsford Smith spent
all of his time and money convincing
everyone that flying was a safe and
practical way to transport mail and
people in order to start a successful
airline but once had finally launched
his company it showed them the exact
opposite back then at least it seems
that flying was anything but safe
it seems that almost every other plane
that Kingsford Smith piloted apart from
the Southern Cross was destined for
tragedy in 1931 he added a new aircraft
to his collection the Avro avian Mach 5
he dubbed it the Southern Cross minor he
wanted to use it to set a new speed
record for the Australia England flight
but was unsuccessful he sold it a few
years later to another aviation pioneer
British pilot bill Lancaster Lancaster
had a career worthy of mentioned him it
mirrored that of Kingsford Smith and was
highlighted by triumphs controversies
and death he also started flying during
World War one and later pursued it as a
career in 1927 he achieved one of the
longest flights in a small aircraft by
journeying from England to Australia he
was accompanied by his lover
Jesse chubby Miller who became a
successful aviatrix in own right a few
years later the two were living in Miami
Florida
why Lancaster was in Mexico looking for
work they brought in a writer named
Hayden Clark who helped Miller write her
memoirs they started an affair and
Miller even decided to leave Lancaster
for her new beau upon hearing this the
aviator he returned home and soon enough
Clark was found dead from a gunshot to
the head
Lancaster was charged with murder his
alibi didn't hold water and he admitted
to forging two suicide notes he had
recently purchased a revolver and
witnesses heard him say that he would
get rid of Clark you think that this
would be a rather
open-and-shut case but Lancaster was
actually found not guilty
he might have dodged prison bits his
reputation took a big hit in Lancaster
became a pariah he was desperate to
regain just a fraction of his lost
prestige and that is where the Southern
Cross miner came in Lancaster decided to
go for the England to South Africa speed
record as that was the in vogue flight
of the day he bought the plane from
Kingsford Smith and set off on April the
11th 1933 everything that could go wrong
though it did Lancaster had gotten lost
several times and fell behind schedule
he was also so sleep-deprived that
officials tried to detain him when he
landed for refueling he ignored them and
pressed on and crashed in the Sahara
Desert miraculously the pilot escaped
from the audio almost unscathed he did
have a serious problem though is he was
now stranded in the middle of the Sahara
Desert with very few supplies he waited
to be rescued occasionally firing off
flares that the rescue never came
Lancaster died eight days later on April
the 20th 1933 it was
almost 30 years before French troops
found his mummified corpse and the wreck
of the Southern Cross minor he had left
behind a diary detailing his last days
on earth which was later published with
miller's permission what's left of the
plane sits in the queensland museum in
1935 Kingsman smith had a very close
call in the Southern Cross while
attempting the first trans-tasman m/l
flight one of the planes three motors
stops due to a damaged propeller blade
the three men aboard the craft only
survived Lucas Matthysse co-pilots P G
Taylor climbed out to the chorus and
transferred oil from the dead motor to
the others using a suitcase and a
thermos flask Kingsford Smith had to
dump all the mail in cargo and barely
made it back to Sydney this was a sign
that perhaps it was time to retire the
Southern Cross smithy purchased a new
plane a Lockheed Altair called the lady
Southern Cross
he sold his famous airplane to the
Commonwealth of Australia so that it
could be put on display in a museum at
first the new aircraft appeared to be a
worthy replacement with it Kingsford
Smith performed the first Eastwood
flight over the Pacific Ocean going from
Australia to the United States in 1935
he decided to use it in order to break
the England to Australia speed record he
set off on November 6 1935 with smithy
where's copilot Tommy petty bridge his
longtime flying partner Charles Ulm had
vanished and presumably had died a year
prior while flying over the Hawaiian
Islands unfortunately this was a fate
that the two would share because the
lady Southern Cross also disappeared
over the ocean on November the eighth it
took off from India and was headed to
Singapore but it was never seen again
it is presumed the plane crashed in the
Andaman Sea off the coast of Burma
killing Charles Kingsford Smith and his
co-pilot a year and a half after the
disappearance and undercarriage leg and
wheel washed up on the shore of an
island and remains the only part ever
recovered from the lady Southern Cross
in recent times filmmaker damien leigh
claimed in 2009 to have found the
wreckage of the airplane his
proclamation has been met with much
skepticism from experts and aviation
historians he has not made the location
public and presumably is still trying to
raise funds for a recovery expedition so
I really hope you found their video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe got brand new videos
just like this four times
we also please do check at our sponsor
link below as always thank you for
watching
[Music]